live from the headquarters of Ramsey
solutions it's the Dave Ramsey show
we're debt is dumb cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice I'm Dave Ramsey your
host this is a show about you your life
your money it's about you winning out
there in the marketplace open phones a
triple eight a two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five one of my favorite new
hobbies here on the air is to take calls
from those of you that have managed to
end up in the millionaire column you
have become a millionaire millionaire is
someone who has a million dollar
$1,000,000 or greater net worth that is
calculated by what you own minus what
you owe so when you hear idiot
politicians say things like a
millionaire there's a millionaire that
and B will make a million dollars here
making a million dollars here has
nothing to do with being a millionaire
that's a politician that's an idiot
which is really not hard to find so or
it's a friend that's an idiot and
sometimes those aren't hard to find know
what they're talking about and so a
Millionaire is someone who has a
$1,000,000 or greater net worth and I've
been studying those folks and I've been
putting out we didn't been doing
millionaire theme hours and you know
letting you hear from them how they did
it
so that if you're not one of those yet
you can get to be one now does it matter
that you're a millionaire or not no it
doesn't matter God loves you either way
but it just gives you options options to
change your family tree options to
retire with dignity options to do
Christmas wherever you want to do
Christmas you don't have to choose one
of my goals a friend of mine used to say
this years ago he said I want to make
enough money that I can finally go into
a restaurant and read a menu left to
right most people read menus right to
left don't they they start with the
price then they figure out what they're
going to get I want to build on to build
enough net worth that I can just order
what I want in a rest
and then I look over and see what it
costs I don't look at it I want the
cheaper chicken I want the cheaper
chicken every time give me the chicken
it's what you're special you know
instead I'm just going to have a meal
and pay for it and you know it takes a
lot of money to get to where your brain
comes loose and allows you to do that
because you know we practice frugality
we practice conservative financial
habits in order to get there and then we
get there the old habits die hard and
you know the other is an art form to
enjoying your money and part of enjoying
your money of course is outrageous
generosity which is the most joy you'll
ever get from money is actually giving
it and as I've been doing this
millionaire thing and pushing out I've
gotten lots of attacks from the haters
and the trolls and the blogs and the
crazies that are out there and you know
I've often thought about this what what
is the role of this show and I had a guy
speaking to us this morning Donald
Miller's a friend of mine we were
talking about this and he got a
different framework I looking at it this
morning than ever before there's a group
of people of course that tell you you
know oh if you're a millionaire you must
have inherited your money because it's
the only way to have money and the same
group of people or a similar group of
people are saying well 1% if you looked
at the income distributions in the world
they're just not fair
the evil 1% the operation Occupy Wall
Street group right and there's all this
flailing around on the internet if you
haven't seen it you haven't just run
across this group of thought that's out
there the socialism basically a
redistribution of wealth wealth is
unfairly distributed another lady that
writes hateful articles about me pretty
regularly says Dave just does not
understand that there are structural
problems with the economy which is a
liberals way of saying you're trapped
you're a victim you can't get out unless
policies are changed in Washington to
allow you to win that's basically what
she's saying structural problems with
the economy systemic is another word
that's often used
here's structural problems with the
economy are systemic these systems are
broken in otherwise there are unseen
systems at work and you know the little
man can't get ahead is the way they used
to say it in my neighborhood just can't
get ahead the big corporations they got
a relative is the corporation the
corporations even though the corporation
is and just yelling about corporations
and vague boogeyman sense the
corporation's Wall Street Wall Street
Wall Street Wall Street and don't even
know what that means but just has this
vague sense that there's a boogeyman out
that's got him trapped and you can't get
ahead because this boogeyman is out
there the difference in the people that
believe that way and what we believe on
this show is those people think you are
a victim I don't I think you're a hero
you may be yet to live out your hero
story but I think you're you may be
unsure as to whether or not you'll be
able to do it to go leave the cave kill
something and drag at home I don't
believe I can be a millionaire I don't
know if it can happen but I'm the guy
that says you can I think you can as a
matter of fact I firmly believe
mathematically virtually anyone in
America can become a millionaire in the
scope of their working lifetime if they
set about a plan of doing it I don't
think you're a victim and I don't think
there are systemic and structural
problems with the economy that only
socialism or wealth redistribution was
the only way you will allow be allowed
to build wealth and that's why I
continually remind you that people who
think of themselves as being heroes in
their own story meaning they believe
they can win they're the ones that start
from nothing an 88% 9 out of 10 of
America's millionaires are
first-generation rich they did not have
a silver spoon they did not most of them
had a lot of them had very humble
upbringing and the kid that lived next
door is
going humble and they became
millionaires what's the difference in
the two mindset and the belief of
whether you believe you're a victim that
you're trapped and that the forces
beyond your control are holding you back
that's a type of victimhood if you
believe that that belief is doing you
more harm than anything else see I
believe you can win because I have
people stand in my lobby almost every
day and scream that they're debt-free
that have overcome unbelievable odds
have lost spouses jobs had medical
problems
law have moved have been deployed have
one kid two twenty two kids I mean it's
amazing they've had marriage problems
they've gone through divorces they got
married they that every possible human
flaw and problem has shown up and they
won anyway and they make me believe that
you can win and so I'm here to remind
you you're not a victim
you're a hero looking for a story you're
going to win rocky music in the
background you're standing at the top of
those steps with your hands in the air
oh yeah you can do it that's why I keep
coming down here and doing this show
because I really believe you can do this
this is the Dave Ramsey show